lilia us manova likes to joke that
coffees good for one's nerves and these
days her family needs nerves of steel
ever since the power went out across the
annexed Crimean Peninsula taught our
families like the astronauts say they've
been coming under suspicion many
crimeans blamed tata activists for
blowing up the transmission lines
mistrust prevails but amazon anymore the
Russians aren't saying explicitly that
it was the Crimean Tatars but they refer
to bandit and then I us in an accusing
way others say we should just leave here
and move to Ukraine why we're staying
put no one can intimidate us we're used
to misery will survive this to getting
by without electricity is a challenge
facing everyone here not just Crimean
Tatars in boxee Sarai it's one of the
settlements built in the 1990s for
ethnic Tatars returning to their
ancestral homelands after decades
enforced exile at this local hospital at
least the lab and some vital equipment
or functioning but only because the
director was able to fire up to
emergency generators
excels ready in your moxie mind they're
not really enough we were only able to
use our x-ray machine two days in the
last two weeks the authorities grant us
a little electricity for emergencies but
only for a few hours at night when we
don't need it without electricity the
winter nights in the Crimean capital
simferopol are especially dark a few
days ago a new power line connecting
Crimea to the Russian grid went into
operation but that's not enough the
peninsula clearly needs more electricity
only those with their own generators can
turn on their lights and they're in the
minority it's darkened ramiyah gloomy
most of Crimea's 2 million people have
been hit by the power cut and they are
still facing this black out public
transport is still running and hospitals
are using generators but the power cut
blanched the streets of Crimea into
darkness that's why it's hard to find
our way back to the osmond off house the
generator is too noisy for conversation
outdoors so we're brought into their
cozy kitchen
the neighbors who can't afford a
generator often drop by to chat with us
and play cards this year lunatic Lily
asthma Nova is holding out hope that the
blackout will at least help bring the
people of Crimea a little closer instead
of stirring up more hate and suspicion